Mental disorders are much more common than many of us think. Almost half of us
will experience a mental disorder at some time in our lifetime. According to
the main guide for clinical psychologists, the DSM-5, diagnosing mental
disorders involves all four of the four D's: Disturbance, Dysfunction,
Distress, and Deviance. There are many different categories of disorders but
some of the major ones are those experienced in childhood. Like autism spectrum
or ADHD. Mood disorders, such as anxiety disorders, depression, and bipolar
disorder. Obsessive-compulsive disorders. Post-traumatic stress disorder.
Dissociative disorders. Bodily-somatic disorders. Personality disorders. And,
finally, the major thought disorder known as schizophrenia. Now, remember, a
very important point about disorders is that there is a range from normal to
dysfunctional. And everyone experiences everyday forms of these, but they're
not necessarily actually disorders unless they have all four of those D's:
Disturbance, Dysfunction, Distress, and Deviance.